here are some common questions to ask
when you clean up data
do variables have valid values are
numeric variables within range
are there missing values are there
duplicated values
are values unique for some variables for
example id variables
are the dates valid do we need to
combine multiple data files
it is important to check those questions
and handle them appropriately in the
data cleanup process
while it is straightforward to handle
some of those issues dealing with others
might not be as simple
for example handling missing values
usually requires good understanding of
the problem context
and can take many alternative approaches
there are many commercial and open
source tools for data cleanup
two very popular open source tools are
openrefine and datawrangler
the tools can greatly help many common
data exploration tasks
you are encouraged to explore their
websites to learn more
next we move on to data transformation
which usually means that we apply a
mathematical function to each data value
perhaps the most common data
transformation is centering and scaling
of a single variable
for those of you with statistics
background you can think of it as
calculating the z-score of each observed
value
that is each data value is first reduced
by the mean
and then divided by the standard
deviation one of the immediate benefits
of centering and scaling
is to make numerical procedures easier
to work with and more stable
this is because the centering and
scaling ensures that multiple variables
in a data set is on a common scale
centering and scaling is often required
or recommended for some modeling tools
such as clustering principle component
analysis and neural networks
the main drawback is that the data
becomes harder to interpret
the data value after centering and
scaling measures the number of standard
deviations between each data point
and the mean
there are many other data
transformations
some of them can be expressed using
common mathematical functions such
logarithm square square root and inverse
except for the first one all
transformations mentioned here
are considered polynomial
transformations
because they involve polynomial terms of
the original data value
different transformations are
appropriate for different problem
contexts
sometimes we have to experiment to
figure out the right one to use
each of those transformation can be
easily done in excel
and other data analysis tools there are
ways to automatically determine the
appropriate data transformation from the
data
an example is box cox transformation
which is defined using
a parameter called lambda different
lambda values give different
transformation
when lambda is zero the transformation
is simply a logarithm transformation
when lambda not zero it is a polynomial
transformation with a parameter lambda
for example when the lambda equals 2 it
is effectively a square transformation
note here that offsetting by 1 and
dividing by lambda does not change the
distribution of the variable
similarly when lambda equals to a half
it is a square root transformation
when lambda equals minus 1 it is the
inverse transformation
lambda can be estimated from the data
itself and can take many different
values
in this way this transformation covers
all transformations discussed before
the transformations we discussed so far
work on a single variable
this should be contrasted with data
reduction which reduces the data by
generating a smaller set of variables
the purpose of data reduction is to use
a smaller set of variables to capture
most of the information in the original
variables
a widely used data reduction technique
is principal component analysis
which seeks to find weighted averages of
the variables to capture most of
information which is measured by
variance in the data
the newly generated weighted averages
are known as principal components
the principal components are
uncorrelated and ideally a few of them
are able to capture most of the variants
in the data
an important note here is that we need
to first scale the variables before
applying principal component analysis
this is so that the principal components
are not dominated by variables that are
much larger in scale
you